tina und daniel das erste treffen
im b2 cruz habe ich ziemlich viele und
schwierige hausaufgaben am besten wäre
wenn ich jemanden hätte der mir den
manchen dingen hilft gerade mit lesen
habe ich manchmal etwas probleme
vielleicht finde ich ja in meiner klasse
hilfe diese tina zum beispiel die war
richtig gutem unterricht wenn ich doch
nur ihre nummer hätte
jetzt muss ich aber wirklich gehen
nicht dass ich noch zu spät komme
[Musik]
bettina bist du gestern noch gut nach
hause gekommen du hast ausgesehen als ob
du einen schwierigen tag gehabt hättest
du ja gestern war nicht der beste tag
aber egal ich hoffe dass es seiner
freundin auch geschmeckt hat im café ach
du meinst alles ja ja es hat ihr
geschmeckt aber das ist nicht meine
freundin wir waren mit einigen
arbeitskollegen essen sie arbeitet in
meiner abteilung
ach so ich dachte das sei deiner
partnerin
gibt es denn eine frau smith mine
zurzeit bin ich allein stehend aber das
leben als single gefällt mir eigentlich
ganz gut
[Musik]
ich weiß was du meinst du findest sicher
noch die richtige
ich glaube dass sich momentan besser
noch nichts sage auch wenn ich ihm
eigentlich gern sagen würde dass ich ihn
toll finde
liebe leute ich finde es praktisch wenn
wir einen klassensieg machen könnten
was haltet ihr von der idee das finde
ich eine klasse idee vielleicht können
wir uns manchmal so gegenseitig helfen
genau gegenseitige hilfe ist immer viel
wert
wärt ihr so lieb und würdet ihr eure
nummer aufschreiben dann könnte ich
einen chat erstellen
[Musik]
das hast du heute geschickt gemacht mit
daniel du hättest ist auch ganz ohne
meine hilfe geschafft seine nummer zu
bekommen ich fand deine idee mit dem
klassen chat gut das war ganz hilfreich
von dir aber anrufen werde ich ihn
selber
[Musik]
das glaube ich jetzt nicht das ist
daniel los nimmt schon ab hallo daniel
hallo tina du ich verstehe unsere
hausaufgaben irgendwie nicht so richtig
verstehst du sie ich habe sie noch nicht
gemacht was genau macht ihr denn mühe
das lesen fällt mir schwer
kannst du gut deutsch lesen bislang hat
das immer gut geklappt ja hättest du
eventuell heute zeit mir die aufgaben zu
erklären
wir könnten uns ja im café lu treffen
ich werde wirklich froh
klar das kann ich machen möchtest du um
18 uhr ins café kommen dann könnten wir
uns noch vor meiner schicht treffen
das klingt super dann bis 18 uhr
das finde ich lustig ein lern date hat
sich seit meiner jugend nicht mehr
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass ich mich mit tina gut
verstehe ich würde sie nämlich gerne
näher kennenlernen
hallo tina schön dich zu sehen können
wir loslegen
sicher wollen wir uns an einen tisch
setzen
siehst du diesen text verstehe ich
einfach nicht
oh nein jetzt habe ich meine brille
vergessen so blöd du trägst eine brille
[Musik]
ja ich sehe nicht gut
dann lasst uns sprechen üben
[Musik]
das ist doch auch eine gute idee
ich finde tina richtig süß
[Musik]
hast du einen basketballplatz gefunden
oh ja ich fand eine gruppe mit denen ich
jetzt öfter spielen kann
[Musik]
ich kann mir gut vorstellen dass du
super spiels
[Musik]
ach es geht nicht primär um den spaß
und was machst du gern in der freizeit
[Musik]
hallo zusammen ich heiße samuel und ich
produziere für euch diese tina und
daniel hallo hallo samuel wir sind am
ende der ersten staffel die folge 5 ist
das finale valley wissen wollt wie die
geschichte zwischen tina ob da mehr
weitergeht
schaut euch das video das ist schon gibt
was wir wollen aber nicht dass es endet
nein keine angst
aber liebe leute in zukunft wird die
geschichte nicht immer weitergehen
es gibt er das schaffe zwei verschiedene
geschichten die hier auch einzeln
anschauen könnt ihr müsst also nicht
jedes mal alle schauen sondern nur das
aktuelle dass wegen der zukunft euch
sein
ich hoffe ihr seid dabei sie war und
derzeit dabei technische dann hoffe ich
auch dass wir beim nächsten mal dabei
sein wenn es heißt wieder auf daniel
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
[Musik]